MIKE MCMAHON: We
have a company based
in India that needed
the capability
to scale up to 32,000 cores.
But they couldn't
do it in India.
They had to move and do
it here in the States.
And they leveraged GCP
here in the States.
We provided the caching
layer for them to do that.
We stood up and
ran 32,000 cores.
And then a few weeks
later we ran another 32.
So we ran 64,000 cores in a
very short period of time.
That is powerful.
We get into the
environments where,
if it's a large
storage environment
and they need to leverage TCO
and the flexibility of moving
data into GCS, we can
do that on their behalf.
So just that
flexibility is changing
the dynamics of the game.
These are things that
couldn't be done before.
GCP is the only platform that
we see that has that capability
to scale that well, that fast.
And we think we can
take it much larger.